the office they let me dress casually
they were clearing my stuff
hey you been good good well I'm gonna go
to the den get some reading done and
then dinners 7:00 like normal Jim you
don't care about me anymore
well I just literally like two seconds
ago asks you how you're doing sign of
caring not sure you know what you always
do this why don't you just go back to
your then and I'll just do whatever
forget the den I'll just I'll just eat
at the bar tonight laughing now but how
many of us have been in that situation
before that shows that that it
definitely reciprocated you know many of
us have been in Monty's situation where
we've said why is he not reading my
nonverbal cues or in Jim's situation
wondering at how we could get such a
hostile response from a seemingly
innocuous question but even though we
have not all might have been in that
situation that Mandvi and Jim might have
been in all of us have been in a
situation where we might have had an
issue dealing with members of the
opposite sex so in strategic
communications class we learn about the
importance of being able to project our
ideas and communicate effectively with
other people so in a way to be able to
do that more effectively we'd like to
introduce gender communication
techniques and so today we're going to
be talking to you about some of the
gender related communication barriers
that we've come across and identify them
then we're going to talk about some
possible recommendations to help you
rectify those gender communication
barriers and then we're gonna start stop
off by taking action and maybe replaying
the scenario we just saw by actually
applying some of those techniques that
we just learned so let's get things
started let's talk about a few
communication barriers Jing if your
stress is a woman how do you feel well I
cannot speak for our woman but if you're
not feeling the same way treat it as an
example as a woman if I'm stressed out I
want to talk I want to communicate my
feelings not to get suggestions not
criticism and I just want to get
reassurance I want to hear things such
as well I know you're going through a
tough time but everything is going to be
okay so how about guys mark that's
really interesting because I think I'm a
lot of the opposite you know as a guy if
I come back and I'm very stressed I feel
like I need to be left alone I need to
retreat back to my cave get my head
straight and come back and get into the
to the groove of things with a better
better mind on my shoulders so we see
that there's a little bit difference in
how we act when were stressed how about
the way that we like to be healing in a
relationship well I definitely want to
feel special it does not have to be
complicated or expensive for example
something as simple as a hug and
something as expensive as five dollar
flowers from the farmers market that
will all work it doesn't matter what you
do what matters is the signals to
yourself
how about guys that's really interesting
to know from a guy's perspective I just
feel like I need to be needed you know
it's not that I want to be in a needy
relationship it's not that I need to
feel that I'm always being acknowledged
but just to know that I'm still abuse
you know sometimes it gets into the
situation where you just go through the
daily grind of things and you forget the
importance of
but speaking of which in relationships
what do you think women are like women I
liken to the waves so sometimes we are
happy and sometimes not so much so it's
natural we are not crazy and I suspect
women's emotional psycho has something
to do with a typical behavior guys do
when they are in relationships you want
to talk about that work well that's very
interesting that you mention that
because when I guess when I'm in a
relationship or any type of relationship
for that matter you know I consider
myself more like a rubber band
sometimes I wouldn't be very close but
other times I need to step back and have
a little bit of free space some autonomy
that doesn't mean I don't care it just
means I need a little bit of free time
to myself and I'm sorry if that makes
you feel crazy but let's talk a little
bit further about some possible best
practices and recommendations that we
could go about and being able to address
some of these communication barriers
that result between the genders so why
don't we start off yang would you like
to talk about one of these
recommendations sure first one if you
are in a fight do not panic always
remember to stay on your side of the net
that means if you are the person who
feels hurt and you want to express your
feelings be very careful now to blame
the other person on the other side if
you are the person who's taking the
complaints be careful that the other
person is not trying to personally
attack you there are four important
words that you all need to remember it's
not your fault
it works wonders try next time it might
save your life
is to practice and Percy here a Stanford
we talked about embassy all the time but
the key is to practice practice and
practice so how to do that just as a
quick reminder reminder here at the base
we need to build up understanding and
respect for our differences and around
the space we want to have good
techniques we want to listen well and we
want to ask questions to validate
whether we got the message right and the
last most importantly we want to give
the reassurance everything is fine I
hear you but there's one more really
important thing now the first two rules
you should be aware of especially if
you're out the GSB and I'm taking
touchy-feely you know practice empathy
you know stay on your side of the net
but there's a third important rule that
I think we need to go over and when it
comes to the importance of gender
communication and that is the golden
rule more specifically do not practice
the golden rule what is the golden rule
do unto others as you would like to be
done onto yourself now I hope you've
seen throughout this presentation a lot
of times that the needs of one gender
might not necessarily be the same needs
of the other gender we all have
different needs we all have different
ways in which we process information and
that's most certainly true between the
genders so when it comes to being able
to communicate with a member of the
opposite gender put yourself in that
person's shoes and realize that their
needs might not be the same needs that
you may have so we've talked about a few
of the issues that result from gender
communication we've shared a few
recommendations but what good are they
if we don't see them practiced so why
don't we go over the scenario that we
first went over when we started this
presentation and apply some of these
techniques with a few commentary here
Jim uses empathy these emotions and
realize that her nonverbal cues is what
he should be paying attention to some
things I feel that you don't appreciate
me anymore I mean I know that you're
busy at work and things like that but
when you come back home and walk
straight to the den I feel like you
don't want to talk to me anymore
and Mandy ups the ante by staying on her
side of the net she doesn't attribute
her upsetness to his behavior but rather
to the emotions I had no ideas made me
feel that way I literally worked so hard
to sit and as an effort to try to make
you happy why don't we you know screw
the den let's uh go get dinner so yeah
movie they even wanted to see that's so
sweet of you Jim Jim knocked it off the
ballpark by actually using not
forgetting Golden Rule and actually
doing something that he knew Monte
wanted to do rather than what he might
have wanted to do but watch him really
knock it out of the park I was literally
just thinking today how lucky I am just
abuse
if only there was some you know action
item I could do to make sure that I
remember these best practices when we're
in the heat of the battle kind of
acronym or something acronym right hmmm
right it's so easy s e-g say must be on
your side of the net e for empathize
with your partner's feelings and lastly
G for the Golden Rule no no you always
did it wrong you don't want to follow
the golden rule it should be